نهائي كاس العالم اللعب الاحد لكن ما زال
طبعا العنوان الاول في المنصات فجرا وصل
حامل اللقب المنتخب الارجنتيني لبلاده كان
الاستقبال الحافل وحاشي طبعا رغم ان الشمس
حتى ما كانت طلعت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من دقائق كمان وصل المنتخب
العاصمه للاحتفال مع الجماهير طبعا هذه
الصور مباشره الان من وسط العاصمه
الارجنتينيه بيونس ايرس وطبعا بحسب
الاحصاءات الاوليه يبدو انه في 100,000
مشجع مجتمعين هناك ليه تحيه المنتخب
الارجنتيني اللي فاز للمره الثالثه
ببطوله كاس العالم وهذه المره فاز على
فرنسا طبعا في احتفاء خاصه
بمسي وفي تقدير خاص لمسي خصوصا انه بهذا
الانجاز يعد الانجاز كبير بالنسبه له
شخصيا وعلى مستوى طبعا ايضا المنتخب الصحف
الارجنتينيه اليوم كلها بتتحدث عن ميسي
وتشكره طبعا ايضا بتتحدث
طبعا في هذا الموقف كمان ايضا ما ننسى
يعني لو الصور كانت دخلت زووم اكثر كنا
هنشوف ايضا انه في كثير من اللي واقفين
حاملين صوره مارادونا الحاضر الغائب في
هذا
الانجاز فطبعا صوره وظهرت في الاحتفالات
محموله وايضا حتى في على الصحف
وكمان خلينا بس نتذكر من اليوم كان في
اجازه رسميه او اعلن عن اجازه رسميه في
الارجنتين احتفاء بهذا الانجاز
على المنصات ومع الفيديوهات في صور كثير
كمان متداوله وبتعكس الفرح والنصر
والمراسم الاحتفاليه بالمنتخب الارجنتيني
ومثل ما قلت لكم مشاهدينا تحديدا ميسي
[موسيقى]